welcome back weight and wellness go hand
in hand so if weight loss is on your
mind regenerate medical concierge the
sponsors of this segment have three
different programs that can help you
achieve your goal
[Music]
hi i'm dr amin and we're here at my
office regenerate medical concierge
where we do
health and wellness treatments
anti-aging treatments hormone
replacement
and weight loss which we're going to be
discussing today
so weight loss is relatively important
just for global health and wellness and
we had a lot of patients that come in
who are looking for different modalities
of weight loss to help get them to that
place where they can start to be healthy
you know as we get older our dna slows
us down and we start to gain weight
metabolism drops and by the time a lot
of our patients realize they they want
to start being healthy and working out
they realize there's too much weight and
it
it affects their joints and their
ability to actually lose the weight we
have three different modalities that we
use here and each one is ideal for
different types of patients
and because of that i like to start by
interviewing the patients and really
dive deep into what their lifestyle is
what their goal is and then we pick the
right choice for them
you know some of our patients are
already very healthy they eat healthy
they exercise multiple times a week they
do cardio everything they're supposed to
be doing but they still aren't losing
that last 10 15 pounds
for patients like that we'll use our fat
burner shot and what that shot will do
is help them get rid of more fat than
their body is actually using so when
their body is putting fat into the blood
to be used this shot just kind of helps
to
get rid of that fat instead of using it
for fuel
and that shot is just a combination of
amino acids and b12 for energy
our second option is for the
larger population where exercising isn't
quite ideal because of how much they
weigh
and essentially they want us to help
them lose the weight so they can become
healthy and get into the lifestyle and
for that we use hcg so hcg is more
commonly known as the pregnancy hormone
when women are pregnant they their
bodies make hcg men make it too but it's
typically undetectable
when we use it for weight loss it's a
very low dose and we typically see about
a pound per day as far as weight loss
for men and women
however post-menopausal women because of
changes to their hormones will lose
about a half a pound a day
and unlike your fad diets and things
that we see on tv and the internet the
results with this diet plan are typical
meaning that every patient we've dealt
with has lost a pound a day our third
option is semi-glutide
this medication is relatively old has
been it's been around and been used for
diabetics and most recently was just
repurposed and uh
is now being used for weight loss it
works in a completely different way it
actually causes us to feel like we're
full sooner so the results we're seeing
are fantastic you know one of the nice
things about a health and wellness
clinic is people come here seeking a
solution and we have it for them you
know some of our biggest losses include
we've had two men that have lost upwards
of
170 pounds just continually doing the
plan and sticking to the diet
we are also looking to add a nutrition a
nutritionist to help our patients after
they're done with the weight loss
regenerate medical concierge are located
in henderson for more you can call
702-998-8009 or visit
regeneratemedicalconcierge.com
we'll be right back